there is a mathematical connection
between the Egyptian pyramids the
Parthenon in Athens and spirals in
flowers in nature the ratio of the long
side of the pyramid to its base the
ratio of the width of the Parthenon to
its height and the spirals are all
connected by the golden ratio this is
denoted by the lowercase Greek letter
Phi and it's equal to the square root of
Phi plus 1 over 2 or approximately 1.6
the golden ratio is a very famous
mathematical constant recently a 15 year
old at the Boston Science Museum saw the
golden ratio was written as the square
root of 5 minus 1 over 2 believing this
was an error he told the museum about it
and the museum admitted that oh this
negative sign should actually be a
positive sign this was picked up by the
media and everyone went crazy but what's
even more interesting is that recently
the museum said no actually we are
correct this is the golden ratio it's a
different way to write the golden ratio
so now everyone is confused about what
the golden ratio is and why these two
things would be equivalent so let me try
and clear up the controversy let's look
at a rectangle which has a width of 2
and a height of 1 if I ask you what's
the ratio of the two sides there are
actually two different ways you could
tell me what the ratio is if you told me
the ratio of the longer side to the
shorter side you would tell me the ratio
of the sides is 2 but you could also
tell me the ratio of the shorter side to
the longer side in which case you would
say the ratio is 1/2 or 0.5 now consider
a golden rectangle where one side is the
golden ratio and the other side is 1 if
you told me the longer side to the
shorter side you would have the square
root of 5 plus 1 over 2 is the ratio of
the sides or approximately 1.618 but you
can also tell me the ratio of the
shorter side to the longer side which is
the reciprocal
this is sometimes denoted by the capital
letter Phi and that's equal to 0.61
eight so there are two different ways
that you could express the ratio of the
sides and that's why both of these are
correct ways of expressing the golden
ratio so just to give one technical
aside I said these two are reciprocals
of each other they do not look like
reciprocals so let's verify this
mathematically if you multiply the two
numbers together and simplify you'll
find out they're equal to one two
numbers that multiply together to equal
one are reciprocals another way you
could verify this is by taking the
reciprocal of Phi you then need to
rationalize the denominator and then if
you do a little bit of algebra you'll
find out you'll get to the capital Greek
letter Phi which is the square root of 5
minus 1 over 2 so what all this means is
that the golden ratio is typically
written as the square root of 5 plus 1
over 2 which is the ratio of the longer
side to the shorter side this is
approximately 1.618
but you could equivalently look at the
golden ratio as the capital Greek letter
Phi is a square root of 5 minus 1 over 2
and this is the ratio of the shorter
side to the longer side and that's
approximately 0.618 so both ways are
correct ways of expressing the golden
ratio and that's because you can express
ratios either as the longer side to the
shorter side or as a shorter side to the
longer side thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
also catch me on social media at
pressure Walker and if you like this
video please check out my books there's
a link in the video description